[Music]
Dead Rising 4 has us returning to
Willamette and its new zombie infested
mall for the first time in 10 years
the game is brand spanking new megaplex
offers dozens of shops for us to pick up
some stylish outfits to wear so if
you're looking to nab some new threads
for a night of zombie bashing you've
come to the right place 1 something
simple something that screams young at
heart
grab some shirts for mad love tees or
Bobby bombers whether you're into video
game themed apparel or prefer solid
colors they're bound to have something
you like or maybe you're looking for
something a little bit more outdoorsy
stop by the Caribbean Cove area of the
mall and pick up a wetsuit and snorkel
or go next door for all things winter
sports and if you're more of a team
player
get yourself a uniform from sport rinse
at the north end no matter what you like
to play through your number one stop for
all your sports ball needs now if you're
the sophisticated type and can't stand
the thought of wearing jeans and the
tank top check out big man's clothing
located on the east side of the mall
throw in some slacks a blazer finish it
off with a nice turtleneck and boy
you're gonna have the ladies crawling
all over you and as a bonus smash the
window next door and grab the sweater
courtesy of your favorite children's
show host
[Music]
a beautiful day in the neighborhood
indeed but if you really want a dress to
impress
we've got you covered head on over to
Albert's apparel for the fanciest of all
tuxedos if you're into that sort of
thing or I would recommend checking out
the even nicer suits of armor that is
the medieval town museum has everything
you need to fulfill your knighthood
fantasies but just because you're all
dressed up doesn't mean you need to
forget about that special lady friend in
your life pick her something up from
Alyssa couture
maybe a business suit for the working
type or perhaps a nice cashmere outfit
remember the shop around though you
never know when you might find that
perfect summer dress just don't forget
to wash the blow-off before giving it to
her and if all you're looking for is a
good megaman themed outfit well you're
in luck to pop in the key to real Plaza
has all your capcom favorites from
street fighter sweaters and masks to
luchador clothes and yes even a full
body bass costume it may not be 0 but
it's just as fashionable
[Music]
but hey I think we all really know what
the best looking outfit here is well the
dinosaurs head to toy recs in the
northernmost area of the mall and there
you'll find all sorts of children's play
things including the best t-rex costume
this side of Willemijn they say the
clothes make the man so I'm not sure
what that makes Frank West but I hope
you all learned a thing or two about
dressing yourselves in Dead Rising for
whatever your outfit of choices just
remember one thing keep it classy
[Music]
[Music]